ma cosa ma ecco che cosa cazzo sto
giocando ragazzo bello e tutti ragazzi e
benvenuti questo video sono fa vj anzi
ragazzi siamo su turbo lo zio sono sto
partito malissimo familiari ok
bene bene perché è la faccia bellissima
ascolta eccoci qua perfetto anche
ragazzi sono tornati su turbo dismount
la cosa [ __ ] che hanno aggiunto un
casino di roba tipo i personaggi nuovi
tipo questo è stupendo la mia faccia o
mio dio cos'è questo questo e spaventosi
simo ci sembra tipo un ragno è
bruttissimo è la cosa più brutta che
abbia mai visto in vita mia
giuro evra mia patente ecco a parte la
pancia tagro appena dato è una roba
patria dove sto andando ragazzo mio dio
ed è bellissimo e perfetto ho raggiunto
occasioni personaggi tra cui anche
questo che è un colosso sono fratello
così comunque seriamente una scimpanzè
enorme c'era ragazzi sto gioco dopo ogni
[ __ ] aggiornamento e diventa sempre
più non senza ok sono diventato un
cornetto miss diva miss diva è che
l'omino michelin qui a dio cioè questo
c'è la testa enorme
ovviamente è un aspetto mio dio fa cose
ma mi aggiornava avere da questa è
inguardabile perfetto stuprerò mentre
dormi comunque ragazzi a parte la sec
saggine dei personaggi hanno aggiunto
anche un casino di livelli nuovi tipo
questo che sarebbe tipo cosa stai
facendo non sono neanche partito sto già
sbandando fantastiche livello completato
non lo fai tu non vuoi passa ma va
chebanca dovrei riuscire a cosa o mio
dio credo che così io riesca a farcela
forza dovrei riuscire a portare questo
la macchina fino alla fine niente son
caduto io pesa mi sembra mi sembra più
che bella infatti dovrebbe essere più
efficace di quella di prima spero forse
no ecco forse ecco non è esattamente non
così anzi mi devono investire che se non
so chi guarda che roba
c'è ma non sei contento proprio devo
fare a cambio pure bastardi fan costo
livello lo faccia una volta per tutte lo
finisco perché non ne posso più perfetto
la prima curva è andata lega ma anche
alla prossima se riesco a far questa
l'ho finito ma so già che c'è sono in
piedi non c'e non ci credo non ci posso
credere che ho fatto è stato alquanto
figo ragazzi proprio questo che mi
sembra che carino sterling
cosa fa con questo guido io serio non
regga basta da quando hanno aggiunto sta
cosa il mio è diventato il mio gioco
preferito in assoluto che la pula e
vabbè io aspettavo soltanto che
aggiungessero questa cosa in un turbo di
smart bellissimo pulito cosa ho fatto
basta non lo voglio replay ragazzi
sparatevi sta roba come gli o schivati
madonna ma neanche james bond non
dovevate mette all'asta giunta proprio è
diventato una merda ma se tipo guida
assist a roma lo travolgono ma è così
fuori stronza di madonna lo pirato
sottile
magari ho fatto un culo così dei chiari
da adesso lascia andare solo perché sono
perché natale se non a caso mi dovete
spiegare delle cose
ok che cosa sta succedendo morto partita
la pura ma cosa c'è contro quel triciclo
ma è stupida vai vai vai vai vai mai
gira gira ma ho fatto sbattere i tre si
stronzo forte prima questo ragazzo un
gioco bello adesso diventato un gioco
strafigo che sa è un circuito di formula
1 fatevi prendere la ecco questa è la
macchina serie levatevi dai cazzo che
guido io mio zio michè non è esattamente
così che si guida sono diventato un
pezzo
ero diventato un culo che cosa brutta
fermate fermati ma sei la mia macchina
almeno tu dammi un po di rispetto
guarda mia testa dove andata finì la mia
testa dai dai che la prendo da che
apprendo dai che la freccia ma no ma no
ma cosa si prova ragazzi perché è
bellissima sta cosa come fa ad andare
più veloci me con un carretto lo vedi
questo zio l'over non so se l'hai visto
ma pardon questa è una cosa proprio da
da kamasutra prove
mio dio ascoltami ecco perfetto come non
detto
lasciamo perdere le cose e sexy sulle
macchine esistono da vicino
all'acceleratore chiamata a freno che si
schiaccia in questi casi però vabbè un
diventato di nuovo un culo ragazzi non
so perché mi trasformo in un culo
madonna lo schivato vogliono tentare il
suicidio di massa proprio così mio zio
ho paura a fare due metri che sta roba
grazie grazie mille meno male ieri una
smart cache seri un camion
come non detto io non ho mai visto una
persona più sexy di questo a fare la
spesa ragazzi che non so voi è la
madonna che salto sta andando in
derapata ste macchine che sta facendo
spiega mi si è staccata la testa e la
moto per il mio dio
[Musica]
troppa roba poco tutta roba dove sta
obama con le medaglie lo voglio adesso
gli altri bellissimo quando si è la ma
che sei superman
ora che non ai superpoteri non trovare
ieri infatti però season al mod
cos'è sta roba ci sono al mondo perché
babbo natale sta nevicando è bellissima
no dai babbo sei troppo un filo fatelo
dire madonna dei per natale voglio una
moto nuova serie c a provare questo
monorail incidente la roba degli
incidenti cos'e non c'è un amore nota è
quella la monorotaia ok ho capito non lo
è ma che cazzo di mira che c'hai non è
porsi ho perso una gamba cioè mi è
scaduta addosso solo un treno persona
gamba bene ragazzi quest'anno babbo
natale troppo trendy
ok eccolo eccolo comincia la
disintegrato comma davvero non la chiamo
dino del replay di questa cosa buona è
la madonna lei disintegra e io sono mi
sono salvato tra l'altro non so come ho
fatto ma va bene così l'it decision
ecco sì sì già faccio vaffan gara che
c'era il pullman già riuscito a beccare
il pullman impossibile fatemi provare
l'ultimo ragazzi del swiss bank si possa
andarci con triciclo con babbo natale
già sta già accadendo in partenza
bellissimo
no no studiano tagliano sulle rotaie non
ci posso credere
posso veramente sere su una rotaia una
non è possibile sta sta succedendo
laggiù
a chi è mio addio tentò di capire che
cosa che senso ha la vita proprio in sé
per sé guarda che roba già fatta ho
fatto un po di case vabbè quali son
dettagli ragazzi fatevi provare l'ultimo
e poi bastano perché voglio sono quello
di far sa cosa mi desse a demolire la
puglia sarà fantastico lui da stronza
vieni qui vieni qua dove vai visto
demolendo una palma perché ce l'ho con
la palma vaffan
se lo presti dove dove andare con ecco
anche questo anche questa no non mancata
di pochissimo
madonna che botta non lo prendo preso in
pieno anche stavolta aveva bellissima è
chiaro ragazzi che concluso che
l'episodio è stato è stata quanto strano
come piscopio ma va bene lo skate board
di provare con lo skateboard e barboni
nostro vieni quando la no ma come vabbè
ragazzi vado dritto fino alla morte era
affanculo con la solita ragazze il video
è piaciuto lasciato argomento mi piace
anche a valiani facebook e come la
divido tratta d'estinzione se anche voi
siete contro i babbo natale maltrattati
cosa sta succedendo lasciato un altro mi
piace sempre si di sky tv diavolo
prossimo video bello ragazzi